Salut,
hier sur twitter je vous ai demandé de quoi j'allais parler aujourd'hui
et vous avez proposé une True Story
je me suis demandé de quoi j'allais vous parler
Et bien simplement: De comment j'ai commencé le mentalisme
qui est sûrement la phrase et la question qu'on m'a le plus posé
Le temps d'installer un petit peu le matériel
Parce qu'on est une équipe, on fait tout ensemble
Mais à une main c'est pas pratique *rires*
Tu es bien accroché? Tu te sens stable?
C'est parti
Générique
*Générique*
Je ne sais plus si je vous ai déjà dit "Salut"
si c'est pas le cas "Re-Salut"
mais si je dit Re-Salut c'est que ça veut dire que j'ai déjà dit "Salut"
Dans une ancienne vidéo, je vous donnais ma définition du mentalisme
je vous invite à cliquer ici
parce que je vais la remettre
et je vous conseille de la regarder
parce qu'elle est importante en fait,
parce que pour moi le mentalisme c'est tout et rien à la fois
ça ne veut rien dire à part pour celui qui utilise ce mot
avec sa définition
Cette vidéo semble la plus claire de la planète
Depuis 321 ou 322 vidéos la question qui a été le plus fréquemment posé ça a été quand même
"Comment est ce que j'ai commencé le mentalisme?"
Donc je vais globaliser, sur comment j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à toutes ces choses là
Quand j'étais petit
Et le premier qui commente "Ah bon parce que tu as grandi entre temps?"
je le banni de la chaine
Quand j'étais petit, ma mère m'a emmené chez un psy
En fait, elle avait une amie qui consultait un psy pour ces enfants
Et ce psy faisait les tests de QI
Les FAMEUX tests de Quotient Intellectuel
donc ma mère m'a emmené là bas, faire ce test de psy
J'avais à peu près 8 ans je crois
et je me souviens vraiment de ça.
C'était dans un village à côté du mien à L'Aubreçay, ça s'appelait
Et j'avais pris ça, un petit peu, comme un jeu
de faire ce test là
Je me souviens vraiment de tous les moments du test
c'est à dire il y avais un test de culture générale
je me souviens qu'on me demandait, si je savais qui été Einstein,
si je savais de quelle origine il était
si je savais pourquoi il était connu.
Je me souviens qu'il y avait des tests de mathématiques relativement simple aussi
Des tests de compréhension sur des choses
Je me souviens également d'un puzzle
qui était composé, aller de 5 pièces ou 6 pièces maximum
Je sais plus ce qu'il représentait
je crois que c'était un chien,
mais je ne fais tout à fait confiance à ma mémoire sur ce coups là
et les pièces étaient imprimées des 2 côtés
donc 5, 6 pièces
EASY
et bien pas si easy
En fait il y avait un problème de logique.
A un moment donné, quand tu faisais le puzzle
tu te rendais compte  que la dernière pièce,
elle n'allait pas passer, en fait
Mais ton cerveau bug et tu veux forcer quand même
alors que tu sais que non
Et en fait, il suffit juste de retourner les pièces et le refaire un petit peu différemment
ça m'a beaucoup agacé
parce que je savais que j'étais en train de perdre du temps bêtement
et j'avais pris ça comme un jeu je vous l'ai dit
donc je voulais gagner le jeu, tu vois.
Et je me rappelle, principalement, de la dernière épreuve
Regarde je dis "épreuve" au lieu de dire test
Le dernier test, c'était un alphabet,
donc toutes les lettres avec un code en face
donc des symboles en face de chaque lettre
Et j'avais... je sais pas trop,
là je vous dis peut être une bêtise
1min30, 2min, 2min30 pour m'imprégner un petit peu de cette alphabet là
et ensuite j'avais un texte à traduire
c'est à dire un texte codé
et j'avais accès, juste à côté de moi sur ma gauche, toujours aux codes
et donc je devais le traduire, le plus rapidement possible
et ce qui s'est passé
La légende raconte,
parce que la légende a peut être un petit peu embelli la chose
Je ne me suis jamais référé aux codes de départ
si ça se trouve je me suis référé 1 ou 2 fois mais pas beaucoup en tout cas
parce que, simplement, j'avais mémorisé en faisant une association d'images par lettres
Chose que je faisais déjà spontanément
et c'est là que le psy a décidé de pousser un petit peu plus loin sur ma mémoire
et qu'on a découvert que j'avais une mémoire un petit peu facilité, on va dire
C'est de là, que j'ai voulu en savoir plus sur la mémoire
et sur comment s'en servir
Alors je vous parlais d'Einstein, il y a 2 minutes
Einstein disait: "Un don non travaillé s'appelle une mauvaise manie"
et ben c'est ça.
c'est ça qui m'a donné, ce terrain un petit peu établi, envie d'aller chercher plus loin
dans tout ce qui était mnémotechnie, visualisation, méthodes d'apprentissage.
Et ça tombe bien parce que c'est là où ma route rencontre celle d'un livre
Je suis donc né dans un village au Nord de La Rochelle
qui s'appelle Marsilly, c'est à 8 Km au Nord
et il y a un vide grenier tout les ans
et à peu près à cette même période
je sais pas trop vous dire, quand exactement
je vais au vide grenier avec 10 francs avec moi
et je m'achète un livre, que je trouve là bas
qui coûte 10 francs.
Il s'appelle *Cour Magica* de Robert Veno
Je vais vous le faire voir, bande de petits veinards
[En chantant] *Ta... ta.... ta... ta...
je ne sais pas pourquoi je chante ça"
Alors déjà faut savoir qu'on est au fin fond de La Rochelle
et c'est un livre, apparemment, qui vient de quelqu'un, d'un parisien
qui vend ça.
C'est toujours marqué
et c'est un... un cour pour débutant
mais à destination vraiment très adultes
de magie, de prestidigitation
Donc avec les anciennes planches de dessins etc..
Mais il y a une section... qui s'appelle...
Je vais vous retrouver le nom
Qui s'appelle "Magnétisme, spiritisme, divination et transmission de pensée"
comme vous pouvez le constater
Alors il y a pas vraiment le mot mentalisme là dedans
mais c'est la première fois que je lis
des choses,
concernant soit le trucage, en fait, du cerveau
on peut dire les astuces qu'on peut faire avec son cerveau
soit les procédés de mnémotechnie
et ça me passionne,
juste ça me passionne
et de là je vais commencé à m'intéresser à toutes ces méthodes là
en plus, de ce que je sais faire de la mémoire
et assez rapidement
j'arrive à me procurer un livre qui est sorti 1 an avant ma naissance
"Psi ou les principes brillants du mentalisme"
L'histoire du mentalisme,
la mémoire du futur,
la télépathie,
alors là quand on parle de la télépathie
c'est au niveau du rendu des effets
Je ne crois pas forcément à la télépathie
c'est pas que j'y crois ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est même pas le propos
et ces 2 choses vont être un point de départ pour moi
pour attiser ma curiosité sur des livres qui sont
moins centré, après, spectacle ou démonstrations
Sur des sujets plus spécifiques
sur le monde scientifique aussi
parce que même si je ne suis pas un vulgarisateur scientifique
comme on l'entend
il n'empêche que je me suis très intéressé
par toutes les découvertes
qui soit récentes ou anciennes
et toutes les conclusions qu'on fait, chaque jours, dans ces domaines là
et c'est ainsi que naissent chez moi
2 vraies passions
la 1ère c'est de...
de faire des démonstrations, de m'exprimer devant les gens
et la 2ème c'est de m'intéresser à tout,
une vraie curiosité exacerbée sur
comment on fonctionne,
comment fonctionne les choses dans l'ordre général
et comment fonctionne le rapport entre les gens
et là je vais littéralement bouffer tous les bouquins de la bibliothèque municipale
et la 3ème choses je commence déjà à avoir envie de transmettre
ce que j'apprends au fur et à mesure que je l'apprend
ou des choses que je comprends ou que je crois avoir comprises
Voilà pour cette true story
vous savez maintenant quel est le point de départ
quel est l'origine de tout ça
mais j'y reviendrai en fin de d'année
Je... j'ai une surprise aussi
pour vous à la fin de l'année
qui va compléter ce qu'on vient de dire aujourd'hui
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo,
j'espère vraiment que ça vous aura plu d'en savoir un petit peu plus de ce côté là
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce [prenant l'accent allemand] en l'air
Je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pris cet accent
mais mettez le, c'est important
et n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaîne en cliquant
alors attendez
en cliquant je pense... par ici
Voilà ça doit être à peu prés par là
ou en cliquant un petit peu plus là, là bas
Vous allez découvrir le magnifique nouveau fond
qui a été fait par Mélanie
Une nouvelle personne qui m'aide en ce moment
Rendez vous demain à... 17h
Tchao !